if he needs to  pump up his net worth  or he needs to borrow money he goes look  at this beautiful asset look at this  perfect golf course worth 50 million  dollars  loan me 25 million because i've got this  50 million dollar asset i can put i can  prop up as collateral for it okay on the  other hand if it's hey  you've got to pay taxes you've got to  pay taxes on this 50 million or as the  town believed it was 15 million asset  trump goes listen i don't have any money  uh first of all  this is only worth 1.4 million dollars  so the taxes should be levied on that  amount and i don't even have the money  to pay taxes as if it were worth 15  million dollars this is similar to  keeping two sets of books it's not the  same it's similar to keeping two sets of  books which is not allowed  and this is now part of this new probe  so  no big shock just another data point  that this was a technique that donald  trump used we knew it already